[Music]
all right now we continue with my
exclusive interview with the 45th
president Donald J Trump where we
discussed Biden's failing foreign policy
including the disaster that was known as
the Afghanistan withdrawal now remember
it was Joe Biden who abandoned our
fellow Americans Behind Enemy Lines in
Afghanistan and lied because he said 13
days prior that he would never do that
he would never leave until all Americans
were out and while he left Americans
behind well it shows Joe was weak he
didn't keep his promise and by the way
his diplomacy and Reckless foreign
policy is clearly emboldening all of our
adversaries around the globe and causing
concern among our allies now contrast
Biden's failures with Donald Trump's
success you know like destroying the
caliphate Isis that was formed when Joe
was vice president taking out baghdadi
and Associates in solomoni and of course
the historic Abraham Accords uh
de-escalating tensions with North Korea
and of course keeping Iran in check the
whole time and tearing up the disastrous
nuclear deal and so much more I sat down
with the 45th president Donald Trump to
discuss this and so much more take a
look the reason this is happening is too
they don't respect our leader and almost
as importantly when they watch that
horrible withdrawal the way they
withdrew I want I'm the one that got it
down to a very few soldiers I went to
get out too and we would have had a very
similar schedule but I would have taken
the military Outlast I would have taken
the American citizens that you talk
about all the time out and I would have
taken the best equipment in the world
military equipment 85 billion dollars
worth of military equipment we let
Beyond and by the way 13 soldiers were
killed for 18 months under my
conversations with Abdul who's the
leader of the Taliban
we didn't lose one soldier
and when they took the soldiers out
first and everybody's at the airport and
nobody knew what was happening and by
the way a lot of bad people got on those
airplanes okay bad people terrorists a
lot of bad people are on those planes
but we lost 13 soldiers and the thing
that nobody ever talks about we also had
a large number of soldiers horribly
wounded no legs no arms their face was
blown to smithereens
a tremendous number nobody ever talks
about them you told me in a previous
interview that you told the leader of
the Taliban before you ever talked about
any withdrawal any plan withdrawal you
said to me
that in no uncertain terms you would
obliterate him if he dared not to follow
every dotted I cross T comma period
Abdul I did I did had a conversation had
a number of conversations didn't you at
one point tell him I know exactly where
you are and give him the exact
coordinates where he was no I sent him a
picture of his house he said but where
he was at the time he said but why but
why do you send me a picture of my house
I said you have to figure that one out
but I said if you don't
if you do anything from that point on we
didn't lose one soldier
I said if you do anything we're going to
hit you harder than any country has ever
been hit he said I understand your
Excellency and he called me your
Excellency I don't know if he calls by
but I will tell you this we didn't lose
one soldier in 18 months and by the way
Biden got up and made a speech and he
said that
right and they didn't follow the plan we
had a plan that was perfect but they
weren't adhering to it so they would
have adhered to it but they weren't but
we were set to get out of Afghanistan 21
years was ridiculous the other thing we
should have done is kept Bagram we have
an air base
billions and billions of dollars to
build a long time ago not for
Afghanistan but for China one hour away
from where China makes their nuclear
weapons and now China is going to be
occupying it so the difference is is
that you told the head of the Taliban
before you discuss what the actual plan
would be what the consequences would be
if he didn't follow through he
understood that okay so my next question
is now we watch for months when Joe
Biden before the before the withdrawal
we watched the Taliban on the move they
were going from Province to Province to
Province to Province different
leadership of the United States the
opposite it's sort of like the opposite
of when you defeated the caliphate you
pushed them back Province Avenue
Province right I wiped out the Isis the
whole Isis caliphate 100 percent
that's who I tell the story about
General Kane right raisin Kane General
we have great generals we have great
military not the people that are on
television but General Raising Cane we
knocked out the entire Isis caliphate
and do you remember I got it down to 97
I said all right let Russia and these
other countries do it now
and the fake news hit me well he didn't
get a hundred percent I was told that we
couldn't do it I was told that it would
take three years and I did it in three
weeks we have a great military
and they don't they're so embarrassed by
what's happening to this country they're
so embarrassed but we knocked out the
Isis caliphate I took out the two worst
people in the world that killed as you
know that killed many of our many of our
soldiers and our people
when you see soldiers walk in without
legs you know who did that to them but
we did an incredible job and they
respected us they were afraid of us they
respected us
and then all of a sudden this guy pulls
all the soldiers out you don't pull the
soldiers out first you pull the soldiers
out last
and I could just imagine Abdul when they
say the Americans have left Kabul they
have left and Abdul saying this guy's
crazy of course they haven't left
they couldn't believe it
and you know I took a lot of heat when I
called when I spoke to him it was a
rough conversation but you know got
friendlier toward the end to be honest
with you because they were going to do
what I said but the media said why does
he call this person I call this person
because that's where the action is I
called him and he's still The Leader by
the way you know of the Taliban Abdul
and again we didn't lose one soldier in
18 months now in Chicago last week you
lost many people and 70 were shot can
you believe those numbers 70 were shot
in New York where Leticia James rules we
have the worst crime that we've ever had
that's where Leticia James she would
have worked she had a focus on murder
and crime in New York where they walk
into stores with axes and they start
swinging the axes at people that's where
she ought to be focused not on how much
is Mar-A-Lago worth
um
and by the way and protecting banks that
got back their money by the way not One
bank got hurt they didn't get hurt
so when I see that and when I look at
priorities and I see something like took
place today in New York and then you see
all these people being murdered and shot
people are afraid to come here
it's really sad and yet if you think
about it 18 months not one person killed
not one soldier killed in Afghanistan
look at the state of the country under
Donald Trump and now you look 20 months
down the road and Joe Biden's been
president
and you see dramatic drastic changes
drastic now so the only criticism I ever
hear of you is this because people know
we've known each other for almost what
30 years now and people say can you just
tell them not to fight so much can you
just tell them don't say this so much
but if I respond to that yes I have to
fight I'm under siege and I'm running a
country if I didn't fight I wouldn't
have had gasoline at record lows I
wouldn't have had all of the things that
we've done that are so incredible
regeneron look at what we did for the
pandemic what we did for their pandemic
was incredible nobody's ever seen
anything like it now more people died
under Biden
then under me then he goes he says oh I
think it's good well we're losing 300
people a day or 500 people a day his
statement the other day was terrible
about the pandemic his statement about
inflation was you don't even agree that
the pandemic is over do you well you
have 300 to 500 people a day dying so I
would say it's not over that's a lot of
people a lot more people died in 2021
and he inherited three vaccines and
monoclonal antibodies which I think was
underutilized absolutely and I will say
this the vaccines were supposed to take
anywhere from 5 to 12 years and if you
look at throughout the world I would be
willing to bet we saved 75 million
people because in 1917 where you had a
very serious virus flu
as you know 100 million people died
probably ended World War One a lot of
people don't know all the soldiers got
sick yeah I mean it probably ended the
years I don't know if you've ever heard
that it was it sort of put an end to the
war because all the soldiers from both
sides got sick but a hundred million
people died I think it's reasonable to
assume that 50 and maybe more 75 maybe
more would have died we did a great job
got it done in nine months instead of
five to 12 years if you could do it and
you know we've done things that nobody
can believe but our economy was the
strongest we had 164 million people
working that's more people working I
mean right now it's the numbers peanuts
by compared to that
because they show these phony numbers of
3.5 3.6 percent but they don't judge it
right because a lot of people aren't
looking for a job if you're not looking
for a job even though they're capable of
having it they don't have any incentive
to get a job our country is in such
serious trouble and the people
understand it better than you do and
better than I do
the level of anger in this country is
incredible do you think Joe Biden you
watch You observe he said in 60 minutes
this weekend watch me I've been watching
them and I've been playing tapes of them
and I think he is a cognitive wreck he
looks weak frail unhealthy frankly
somewhat decrepit and not up to the job
now I doubt very much that Joe Biden
whatever but could ever even sit down uh
with somebody and have a long form
interview like this do this he can't do
it that I can tell you so okay how does
the world you dealt with these World
doctors you dealt with President XI I I
went to the Summits with Kim Jong-un
you've dealt with him you dealt with
Putin you've dealt with hostile regimes
Iran didn't do much when you were
president either they didn't seem too
inclined to act against us Iran was in
check
North Korea was in check I got along
very well with Kim Jong-un which is
something that you would have ended up
in a nuclear war then
Russia was totally in check and China
was in check did you scare the crap out
of these guys it sounds like what you
said to the Taliban guy here's a picture
of your house well did you do that with
others they knew there was retribution
they knew that we can't sit back and let
these horrible things happen but with
presidency as an example
when you're with presidency and we when
you're with just about all of these
world leaders they're at the top of the
game they are at the top of their game
their sharpest attack they're smart
they're brilliant somebody said I called
presidency a very brilliant guy well
he's in charge of 1.5 billion people
without question and the Press attacks
me how dare he call him brilliant he's
the enemy now that has nothing to do
with it but you have to be really on
your game to deal with these people so I
don't know I mean look I I want to see
great leadership in this country more
important than republican or democrat or
liberal or conservative I want to see
great leadership our country's going to
hell we are a nation in Decline I've
asked you a lot of questions about
January 6th and
uh there were certain things that are
missing I don't know why they didn't
interview Pelosi or the sergeant of arms
or the Capitol Police I recommended the
military go down because I knew there'd
be a mural Bowser and right and they
purposely kept out they showed a lot of
your speeches and stuff but I what I
it's a different question though we had
574 riots in the summer of 2020.
um this was after the Jewish League all
coordinated so and we had thousands of
cops pelted with bricks rocks bottles of
Molotov cocktails
dozens of dead Americans and billions
and billions of property damage at the
time you offered to cities like Portland
over and over again
the National Guard right it was rejected
over and over again
um that's right where's that commission
for this we can't let that happen if I
didn't send the garden against the
governor's wishes right because you know
you have to wait in theory you have to
wait for the governor I think the one
thing I might have done differently
although it proved the point letting the
Democrats go to hell because that's what
they did they've let their states and
cities go to hell they're in such bad
shape their their crime ridden they're
evil places nobody wants to go there
anymore but you know you have to wait
for the governor Democrat Governor to
call and ask for permission to use the
guard if I didn't do it early in
Minneapolis you wouldn't have a city
Sean you wouldn't have a city there I
mean if I didn't if they didn't know I
was going into Seattle remember when
they took over a big chunk of Seattle
they knew we were going and I said we're
going in we couldn't get the governor to
agree we're going in I don't care I may
have done it differently I may have just
done what I had to do autonomous Zone
the crime that was committed and you
know they talk about buildings they were
ripping down they were doing big damage
in Portland to the federal courthouses
Federal buildings
crazy you called my show after you saw
the interview with Horace Lorenzo
Anderson senior right and his young son
his namesake right was killed in that
chopped Chas autonomous Zone
um it raises a lot of questions about
your future one of the things that is
interesting you have all of this going
on around you and all this chaos and
while you were president three years
Trump Russia Russia Russia okay all the
different countries we did more than any
other president how how is it that you
can
be president now post presidency I've
known you 30 years nothing seems to
shake you what is it about you because I
think a lot of people would have
collapsed by now under the stress and
pressure of never-ending investigation
and threats of this legal action and
that legal action and people all over
commentators all over TV saying you
should be arrested he should be this and
that
it doesn't seem to phase you behind
closed doors uh yesterday I was given a
question from a very smart person very
top brilliant guy very successful person
who you know a little bit through
reading about him he said do you mind if
I ask you we're talking about something
and then he said you mind if I ask you a
question you know how do you take it
this is a tough guy too how do you take
that's what I've basically asked how do
you take it
and they said do I have a choice I don't
have a choice because what I did and I
understand I never knew they could be
this evil because they're very evil
people they're very evil if I didn't
stop them and sign into law the statues
act they wanted to rip down all the
statues in this country including the
Jefferson Memorial the Lincoln Memorial
I mean it's not even believable
and as soon as I said it's 10 years in
jail no anything it's 10 years you stay
as soon as I did that everybody went
away you know it's an amazing thing but
I really looked at him I said do I have
a choice
I really don't have a choice I have to
go you have to go forward and I think we
did just about more look we rebuilt our
military all that we have our tax cuts
are greater than any tax cuts in the
history of America they are going to
raise your taxes that's why when it
comes to the election you asked about
the election before
if you want to have high taxes if you
want to have high crime if you would I I
say this it's so Politically Incorrect
they tell me but I don't think so it
gives one of the biggest hints if you
want to have men playing in women's
sports if you want to have all of this
horrible education stuff where they're
you know brainwashing and indoctrinating
your children
but you take a look at all how bad they
are
it's inconceivable that the Republicans
can lose it's inconceivable to me that
they can lose so I just hope the people
uh get out and vote
40 to 48 days from today yeah November
8th uh and that's the other thing so I
was attacked today by democrats from the
state of New York and there's a rule
it's an unwritten law you never do this
politically they won't you won't see
Hunter Biden attack during this 60 to 90
days out before an election nobody gets
attacked they attacked me the good news
is I just heard my poll numbers went up
today my poll numbers went up
when they did a raid on Mar-A-Lago very
substantially my poll numbers went up
for the two phony impeachments the two
fake impeachments so with all I had to
go through
I've done more than just about any
president to you and you know what I
kept this out of Wars I'm the only one
in 70 years I think they said that kept
us out of Wars do you think that their
ultimate goal if you put all of these
things together is they just don't want
you to ever run again for president you
think that is a big part of it in other
words I'll put it another way
if you announced right now I'm not
running in 2024 do you believe all of
this would probably just yeah fade away
maybe they have to make it look good so
it would take a little while yeah I
think we'll go I think that look if you
look at the polls first you're not going
to do that are you first the Republicans
no I'd like to I like this I like it
because we've done such a good job and
because a lot of people say nobody else
could do it and if you look at it it's
it's it's a brutal kind of a thing
because they attack you
and you know if you think about it
doesn't everybody want good education
doesn't everyone want a strong military
does especially nowadays when you look
at what's going on no it's uh it's been
an incredible period of time I'm very
proud of what we've done we've rebuilt
our military we even have space force
you know important space for us remember
when they took over they left at space
force and the military hit them hard and
space force now has turned out to be a
very very important thing hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else